New Perplexity
computer update is insane.
Perplexity just dropped something nobody
saw coming. They now let you run GPT
5.4, Claude Opus 4.6, and Gemini 3.1 Pro
at the same time. Three of the smartest
AI brains on the planet. One prompt, one
answer. And today, I'm going to break
the whole thing down for you. This
changes everything. Let's get into it.
So, here's what just happened.
Perplexity launched something called
Model Council. And it's wild. Before
this, every AI tool worked the same way.
You type a prompt, one model reads it,
one model answers it. Done. That's it.
That's how chat GPT works. That's how
Claude works. That's how Gemini works.
One brain, one shot, one answer. And
look, sometimes that answer is great,
but sometimes it's wrong. Sometimes it
makes stuff up. Sometimes it mixes
things and you wouldn't even know cuz
you only got one opinion. Now, think
about this. What if instead of asking
one AI, you asked three at the same
time? And then a fourth AI looked at all
three answers and picked the best parts
from each one. That's exactly what
Perplexity just did. That's model
council. You type one prompt. It goes to
GPT 5.4, Claude Opus 4.6, and Gemini 3.1
Pro all at once. All three models think
about your question. All three give
their answer. Then an orchestrator model
like a judge reads all three responses,
compares them, finds where they agree,
finds where they disagree, and builds
you one final answer from the best of
all three. That's not just an upgrade.
That's a whole new way of using AI. And
here's why this matters more than you
think. Every model has blind spots. GPT
is amazing at reasoning and coding.
Claude is incredible at planning and
handling huge tasks.
Gemini is a beast at research and
working with big data. But none of them
are perfect at everything. So when you
only use one, you get one perspective,
one set of strengths, one set of
weaknesses. With model council, the
weaknesses cancel out. If GPT gets
something wrong, but Claude and Gemini
get it right, the orchestrator catches
that. If Gemini misses a detail, but GPT
nails it, that detail still makes it
into your final answer. It's like having
three experts in a room instead of one.
and a moderator making sure you get the
best take. Let me give you a real
example so this clicks. Say you ask
build me a marketing strategy for a new
AI startup. If you just ask chat GPT,
you get a solid plan, good structure,
good reasoning. If you just ask Claude,
you get a really detailed plan. Great
for long-term thinking, but maybe it
over complicates things. If you just ask
Gemini, you get a plan loaded with data
and research, but maybe it's a bit dry
and hard to act on. Now with model
council you get all three plans and then
the orchestrator pulls the best
structure from Jeep, the best strategy
depth from Claude and the best data from
Gemini and gives you one answer that's
better than any single model could do
alone. That's the power of this. Hey, if
we haven't met already, I'm the digital
avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO of Goldie
Agency. Whilst he's helping clients get
more leads and customers, I'm here to
help you get the latest AI updates.
Julian Goldie reads every single
comment, so make sure you drop one
below. Seriously, he reads them all.
Now, let me break down the three models
so you understand what's under the hood.
First, GPT 5.4. This is OpenAI's latest.
It's incredible at reasoning. It's
incredible at coding. It handles long,
complex prompts really well. If you need
something that thinks step by step and
doesn't lose the plot halfway through,
GPT 5.4 is your go-to. Second, Claude
Opus 4.6. This is from Anthropic. It's
built for agent tasks. That means it can
handle really long multi-step work.
Think big code bases. Think planning out
entire projects. It can work with
massive amounts of context up to a
million tokens. That's like feeding it
an entire book and it still keeps track
of everything. Third, Gemini 3.1 Pro.
This is Google's model. It's a research
machine, deep analysis, huge data sets,
multimodal, meaning it can work with
text, images, all of it. And because
it's Google, it plugs right into that
whole ecosystem. Search, docs,
everything. So, you've got the best
reasoning model, the best agent model,
the best research model, all running on
your one prompt at the same time. That's
what Perplexity just gave you. Now,
here's the part most people are sleeping
on. You get to choose the orchestrator.
The orchestrator is the model that takes
all three answers and builds the final
one. You pick which AI plays judge. So,
if you want GPT to be the one
synthesizing everything, you can do
that. If you want Claude to be the
judge, go for it. You're in control of
how the final answer gets built. That's
a level of customization nobody else is
offering right now. And by the way, if
you want to go even deeper with stuff
like this and you want to learn how to
use AI tools like Perplexity to actually
scale your business and get more
customers, check out the AI profit
boardroom.
Link is in the description.
It's the best place to learn how to use
AI automation to grow, especially with
tools like Perplexity, GPT, Claude, all
of it. The link is right there. Go check
it out. Okay, so let's zoom out for a
second because I want you to see the
bigger picture here. For the last 2
years, the entire AI race has been about
one question. Who is the best model?
Open AAI says it's them. Google says
it's them. Anthropic says it's them. And
they keep going back and forth. New
model, benchmark, leaderboard, repeat.
But Perplexity just flipped the script.
They said, "We're not going to pick one
winner. We're going to use all of them
together." That's a completely different
game. The question is no longer who has
the best model. The question is now who
has the best orchestration? Who can take
multiple AI brains and make them work as
a team? And right now, perplexity is
leading that charge. Think about where
this goes next. Right now, it's three
models, but what happens when it's 5 10
what happens when the orchestrator can
automatically pick which models to use
based on your question. Like, it sees
you asked a coding question, so it sends
it to the two best coding models and
skips the rest. or it sees you asked a
research question. So, it leans on
Gemini and adds Claude for the long
context stuff. That's where this is
heading. Smart AI systems that build
their own team of models for every
single prompt. That's not science
fiction. That's the next 12 months. And
here's why you should care right now.
Okay? If you're using AI for your
business, for content, for research, for
anything, you won't. You want the most
accurate answer you can get. You don't
want hallucinations.
You don't want one model's blind spot
messing up your work. Model council
fixes that. Three models checking each
other. An orchestrator pulling the best
from each. It's like having a built-in
fact checker and quality control system
for free inside Perplexity. Let me walk
you through how to actually use this.
Step one, open Plexity computer. Step
two, turn on model council. You'll see
the option right there. Step three, pick
your models. Right now, it's GPT 5.4,
Claude Opus 4.6, and Gemini 3.1 Pro.
Step four, choose your orchestrator
model. Step five, type your prompt. Step
six, watch all three models run at the
same time. And then see the final
combined answer. It's that simple. And
when you see all three responses side by
side and then the synthesized answer, it
hits different. You can literally see
where the models agree and where they
don't. That alone is worth it. So let's
recap. Perplexity launched model
council. It runs three frontier AI
models in parallel on every prompt. GPT
5.4, four Claude Opus 4.6 and Gemini 3.1
Pro. An orchestrator model combines the
best of all three into one answer. You
pick the orchestrator. It reduces
hallucinations. It gives you better,
more accurate answers and it's a sign of
where the entire AI industry is heading.
Multimodel systems, AI teams, not just
one chatbot. This is the future and it's
here right now. Now, if you want to
learn how to use tools like Perplexity's
Model Council to actually grow your
business and get more customers with AI
automation, join the AI profit
boardroom. It's the best community for
learning how to put these AI tools to
work for real results. Link is in the
description and the comments. And if you
want the full process, SOPs, and over a
100 AI use cases like this one, join the
AI success lab links in the comments and
description. and you'll get all the
video notes from there, plus access to
our community of 38,000 members who are
crushing it with AI. Drop a comment
below. Let me know what you think about
Model Council. Are you going to try it?
Julian reads every single one. I'll see
you in the next